bonsoir et bienvenue dans le livre de
politique votre rendez-vous politique du
dimanche soir sur Radio sensation en
association avec TV 78 épisode 241 ce
soir mon invité est la députée de
l'Essonne Farida Amrani
[Musique]
bonsoir vous êtes donc député de la
première circonscription de l'Essonne
député la France insoumise une
circonscription qui comprend notamment
la ville d'Évry Courcouronnes la
préfecture et Corbeil-Essonnes aussi
vous avez 46 ans après vos études en
2003 vous devenez agent de maîtrise dans
une communauté d'agglomération Etienne
vous vous engagez ensuite à la CGT et en
2014 vous vous présentez aux municipales
à Évry votre ville et votre liste Front
de Gauche obtient alors quatre sièges
vous devenez alors donc conseillère
municipal candidate aux législatives en
2017 vous êtes battus à 139 voix près
par l'ancien Premier ministre Manuel
Valls un an après c'est Francis choix
qui remporte l'élection face à vous au
second tour une nouvelle fois lors d'une
législative partielle finalement la
troisième tentative sera la bonne pour
vous puisque en 2022 vous êtes élu
député lors des dernières élections
législatives vous êtes donc quelques
membres aujourd'hui de la commission des
affaires sociales à l'Assemblée
nationale et vous êtes très investi sur
les questions liées aux services publics
alors sur le dossier de la réforme des
retraites c'est un dossier qui qui
continue de faire parler encore cette
semaine la première ministre a reçu les
oppositions les syndicats le
gouvernement veut se montrer ouvert au
dialogue les mobilisations elles se
poursuivent par tout en France personne
n'a l'air de vouloir lâcher finalement
les élus de gauche donc vous faites
partie ont appelé à plusieurs reprises
au blocage du pays et au soulèvement de
la jeunesse alors comment est-ce que
vous avez vécu vous en tant que député
toutes ces dernières semaines de
mobilisation alors merci beaucoup déjà
pour votre question effectivement en
tant que député de la circonscription de
l'Essonne et de la première
circonscription de l'Essonne et en tant
qu'agent de service public le service
public me tient particulièrement à coeur
parce que j'estime que le service public
en fait c'est le cœur
de notre République les services publics
et donc du coup la réforme des retraites
comment je l'ai vécu de l'intérieur
quand la Première ministre dit on va on
va discuter on va essayer de proposer de
travailler en concertation c'est super
joli comme moi c'est le discours est
très sympa le dialogue social c'est ce
qu'ils veulent donc déjà quand on parle
de dialogue social c'est-à-dire déjà
c'est avec les organisations syndicales
et il y a eu aucun dialogue social quand
on arrive autour d'une table et qu'on
dit c'est comme ça et pas autrement pour
moi ce n'est pas du dialogue social ils
ont pris aucune proposition d'aucun
syndicat et alors que là c'est un front
syndical c'est à dire que l'Alter
syndicale au complet et contre cette
réforme donc c'est bien quelque chose
qui ne va pas dans cette réforme et au
lieu de travailler effectivement main
dans la main en se disant voilà on a des
propositions on peut travailler on peut
il y a des amendements qu'on propose etc
tout a été rejeté en bloc
qui habituellement une faculté plutôt
gentille plutôt cool
il se passe jamais rien entre guillemets
pas de blocage etc et là c'est la
première fois que l'amphi est aussi
plein qui a une assemblée générale ou
justement il se pose des questions et se
posent la question pour eux mais aussi
pour leur famille pour leur parents moi
j'ai rencontré quelqu'un qui me disait
je me barre effectivement moi j'ai
besoin de rentrer après dans mon du
travail et donc du coup il faut que les
places se libèrent quelque part mais
au-delà de ça je me bats aussi pour mes
parents moi je mets ma mère je ne la
vois pas elle a un travail pénible elle
pourra pas tenir jusqu'à 64 ans alors a
déjà du mal à tenir jusqu'à 60 ans entre
mes 62 ans mais 60 ans 64 ans c'est
impossible parce que elle a déjà mal au
dos elle est déjà cassé de partout elle
a des arrêts maladie des arrêts d'action
de travail elle ne pourra pas aller
jusqu'au bout et le jeune me dit je ne
peux plus voir ma mère dans cet état là
et donc je me bats aussi pour elle pour
ces conditions quand vous écoutez ça ce
que vous avez pas des regrets sur la
stratégie de la France insoumise qui a
été au départ en tout cas pour la
première lecture
me proposer des milliers d'amendements
pour ne pas justement aller au vote pour
empêcher le vote finalement ce vote il
n'était pas si évident que ça en tout
cas en deuxième lecture il aurait pu le
gouvernement n'a pas voulu prendre le
risque tellement ça se jouait à peu de
voix est-ce que finalement ça a pas été
une erreur stratégique de la part d'un
enfant soumise
du gouvernement c'est-à-dire c'est on a
posé les bonnes questions on a travaillé
et tous les amendements qui étaient
posés c'est pas un amendement on change
une virgule c'est un moment qui était
vraiment fondé donc on nous a demandé de
trouver des financements chose qu'on a
fait on a beaucoup travaillé sur les
financements tout a été rejeté donc à un
moment donné on peut pas nous dire qu'on
a fait de l'obstruction loin de là on a
essayé de trouver des solutions
justement pour leur dire vous n'aurez
pas besoin de passer votre retraite
votre réforme parce qu'on va vous
trouver des solutions de financement
essayez de prendre en compte en tout cas
ce qu'on vous propose ça n'a jamais été
le cas ils ont jamais voulu en tenir
compte et ça nous a permis en tout cas
de mettre en évidence en fait les
mensonges et sur les 1200 euros de
pension sur le temps d'annuité de
travail sur sur plein de choses et si on
n'avait pas eu ce temps-là si on n'avait
pas en fait répliqué notamment sur la
condition des femmes jamais ça ne serait
sorti
parce qu'après toute cette séquence
toutes ces tensions qu'on a fait que en
fait en deuxième lecture en deuxième
lecture ça a joué c'est parce qu'en fait
on a mis on a mis en fait
en évidence justement cette
problématiques et les mensonges on
l'aurait pas fait en premier en première
lecture en seconde en symbolique ça sera
peut-être passé largement parce qu'après
toute cette séquence politique sur les
retraites après toutes ces tensions
politiques c'est inactifs qu'on a pu
voir à l'Assemblée nationale est-ce
qu'on va pouvoir finalement passer à
autre chose est-ce que sur les les
textes là que vous êtes en train
d'étudier est-ce que vous vous sentez
que on passe à autre chose honnêtement
c'est pas possible
parce que même sur la sur la la
proposition de loi qui est actuellement
à l'assemblée qui est plutôt le Bien
Vieillir
justement veulent tourner la page c'est
pas possible on ne peut pas tourner la
page parce qu'en fait tout simplement la
population et les Français ne veulent
pas tourner la page donc c'est soit on
va on nous ce qu'on demande c'est le
retrait de cette réforme donc on ira
jusqu'au bout et si nous quand je dis
nous ça veut dire parce que vous le
savez on est un pied dedans un pied
dehors on travaille avec donc à
l'organisation les organisations
syndicales et l'Inter syndicale qui fera
son travail mais nous en tant que
parlementaire on fera le nôtre et
la prise de responsabilité on sait les
prendre nos responsabilités on les
prendra jusqu'au d'ailleurs sur l'aspect
calendrier proposer cette loi
bienveillir juste après la réforme des
retraites
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez en fait
c'était pour tourner la page ils veulent
absolument tourner la page mais ce qui
se rendent pas compte c'est que personne
veut tourner la page personne ne veut
tourner la page et la page ne se
tournera pas comme ça ce n'est pas
possible parce que c'est un pacte cette
réforme va impacter les Français dans
leur chair dans leur corps donc on peut
pas tourner c'est impossible oui on va
utiliser la proposition de loi qui va
arriver bien vieillir pour justement qui
est vide entre vous et moi vide de
substances vraiment on va on va en
reparler justement donc c'est c'est
travaux parlementaires eux ils se
poursuivent avec cette nouvelle loi donc
la proposition de loi du groupe
Renaissance sur le Bien Vieillir alors
donc plus de 2 millions de Français sont
plus de aujourd'hui ont plus de 85 ans
ils seront plus de 5 millions en 2050 il
faut donc anticiper votre collègue
insoumis lui François Ruffin a qualifié
cette proposition de loi de petites
choses minuscules alors justement les
mesures sur la table aujourd'hui ne sont
ne vont pas assez loin pour vous en fait
c'est tellement elle est tellement vide
elle est vraiment vide cette proposition
que la personne qui devait la prendre en
charge chez chez la dans la majorité
c'est retiré n'a pas voulu parce que
c'est rendu compte que en fait ça
propose à travailler avec dans le
rapport Caroline Fiat et ibora bah en
fait il y avait plus rien il n'y avait
rien est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
qu'est-ce qu'elle contient aujourd'hui
cette proposition aujourd'hui vous
imaginez on parle comme vous l'avez dit
de nos aînés donc comment nous aînés
peuvent-ils en fait bien vieillir et ben
on
est sur l'autonomie il y a rien il y a
pas grand chose sur l'autonomie si pour
eux l'autonomie c'est de donner une
carte en fait aux professionnels une
carte professionnelle aux aidants etc
pour moi ça n'apporte rien du tout ça
donner une carte si on donne pas les
moyens parce qu'en fait ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que cette proposition de
loi il y a zéro budget derrière 0 budget
comment on fait avec quoi
les les professionnels de ce secteur là
il faut les former il faut les recruter
donc il faut ouvrir des postes tout ça
ce n'est pas que c'est pas un des
secteurs qui est le plus attractif
aujourd'hui c'est le secteur le plus
difficile et puis avec cette réforme de
retraite parce que c'est un lien en fait
en nous ce qu'on fait on essaie de
mettre le lien entre la réforme des
retraites et le Bien Vieillir si on veut
bien vieillir encore faut-il bien
travailler
et partir à la retraite en bonne santé
et en fait ce que fait ce gouvernement
aujourd'hui c'est que les conditions de
travail se dégradent et que de toute
façon nos aînés ou même moi on finira
tous casser parce que les conditions de
travail sont pas sont pas adaptés et
sont ne sont voilà ne sont pas la
hauteur en fait des attentes des
travailleuses et des travailleurs donc
le principal problème sur cette question
c'est le budget aussi investi pour
moi je veux bien qu'on utilise
le ce qu'ils appellent le financement
par la les taxes de la cigarette
très bien mais c'est pas la totalité et
c'est pas ça qui fera que on a on a un
budget conséquent pour pouvoir avoir
tous les moyens humains financiers pour
que nos aînés aille mieux c'est pas vrai
en attendant en tout cas du budget il y
en a pour la loi de programmation
militaire qui donc sera bientôt soumise
à l'Assemblée nationale un budget
historique donc pour la période 2024
2030 413 milliards d'euros pour répondre
aux nouvelles menaces qui s'accentue
donc ces dernières années entre la
Russie la Chine que pensez-vous de ce
nouveau budget
c'est la politique que veut mener le
gouvernement on le voit bien c'est
rien pour l'humain et tout pour les
armes quelque part c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui quel a été ces dernières
années en fait la problématique on a eu
en France c'est bien la covid donc c'est
bien le problème de santé
et en fait c'est pas les problèmes
d'armes ou de guerre qu'on a eu c'est
plutôt ça donc si il veut mettre autant
de budget sur sur ce poste là c'est
qu'il a besoin d'acheter ou de vente
j'en sais rien je moi je comprends pas
tout en tout cas sur ce sur cette
réforme
sur ce projet loi je suis pas la
commission de défense et nous on aura un
point justement la semaine prochaine
avec les chefs de fil qui est qui qui
sont pour nous monsieur Lachaud le
député la chaux et donc on aura les
vraiment le l'angle politique qui nous
sera dit je ne maîtrise pas en tout cas
en tout cas ces projets là vous voyez
moi je suis pas mais la seule chose que
je peux dire c'est que l'argent il y en
a et en fait ils ont fait le choix de
l'utiliser pour autre chose et pas pour
le pour les Français
[Musique]
toujours avec Farida Amrani député de la
première circonscription de l'Essonne et
membre de la France insoumise avec
plusieurs élus vous avez lancé stop
galère un collectif pour lutter contre
la galère des transports en
Île-de-France avec les problèmes de
train à répétition que l'on connaît vous
réclamez plusieurs mesures dans ce cadre
dans le de dans le cadre de ce collectif
d'abord le gel du tarif du Pass Navigo
donc le forfait mensuel toute zone est
passé de donc à 84 euros 10 contre 75
euros 20 jusque là c'est aujourd'hui un
contresens selon vous d'augmenter les
tarifs des transports en commun dans une
période justement on veut plutôt inciter
les gens à les prendre davantage alors
l'initiative top galère a été faite par
les conseillers régionaux de
l'Île-de-France donc effectivement c'est
la nupes qui s'est fait à ce moment-là
au conseil régional et qui a décidé avec
certains députés de monter ce collectif
ça peut galère
pourquoi ce
collectif Stop galère il a été créé
justement au moment où la région et
Madame Pécresse avait décidé d'augmenter
le Pass navigateur
donc c'était à la fin de l'année 2022
exactement
augmenter le Pass Navigo pour moi n'est
pas un problème entre guillemets si on
augmente on peut augmenter c'est pas ça
le souci c'est à dire que moi je veux
bien payer pour quelque chose qui
fonctionne et qui fonctionne mieux je
veux pas payer pour quelque chose qui ne
fonctionne pas et qui font ça encore
moins bien donc ils ont fait ils ont
pris cette décision là sauf que ça
impacte énormément c'est plus de 100
euros pratiquement par an pour pour les
personnes et dans la famille il y en a
pas qu'un il n'y a pas qu'un seul passe
Navigo il y en a deux ou trois et donc
du coup c'est autant de de financement
qu'il faut trouver pour ces transports
et on galère toujours autant pour autant
galère pour le sur le RER D aujourd'hui
on voit bien moi j'étais ce matin
je l'ai pris encore ce matin plusieurs
trains supprimés exactement vous êtes
très investi à Évry c'est le RER D qui
dessert la ville qui le RER D tout le
monde dit que c'est qu'ils ont la pire
ligne en tout cas mais quels sont les
retours de terrain justement que que
vous avez de la part des
usagers est-ce que c'est quelque chose
de finalement qui n'est plus possible la
galère au quotidien c'est la galère au
quotidien et au-delà de ça c'est pour
trouver aussi un emploi
ou des études pour faire leurs études
les jeunes ne peuvent pas c'est à dire
que ils sont restreints à trouver
quelque chose qui ne leur convient pas
forcément beaucoup de jeunes vont en
voiture à la Faculté d'Évry
Courcouronnes
dans le coin parce qu'ils veulent pas
forcément aller sur Paris alors qu'il
pourrait aller sur Paris sur des
spécialités etc il se restreignent en
fait pour pouvoir avoir des transports
qui fonctionnent et donc du coup il
reste
sur sur Évry ou sur Évry Courcouronnes
mais ceux qui ont pas le choix ceux qui
sont obligés de continuer leurs études
vous allez travailler en ailleurs et
notamment sur Paris sur la galère et ça
contribue à la décratation de leurs
conditions de travail
et le temps de trajet n'est pas compté
en fait dans le temps de travail et pour
certains c'est une heure et demie 1h45
de trajet quand tout va bien quand tout
va bien
ils ont fait le choix de notamment sur
le la ligne du rerd
de mettre en place des ruptures de
charges ce qu'on appelle des ruptures de
chars ça veut dire qu'en fait on
descendu du train pour prendre un autre
train qui va à Paris alors qu'avant il
allait direct
nous moi je plaise avec beaucoup d'élus
de ma circonscription pour la mise en
place de la ligne S et on peut la faire
c'est à dire qu'avant pour aller de
Corbeil à Paris à Gare de Lyon on avait
40 minutes 45 minutes max
aujourd'hui on milite en tout cas avec
quelques années le service était
meilleur que aujourd'hui
sauf que en fait il va se dégrader on
sait qu'il va continuer à se dégrader
parce que tout simplement on construit
des logements sur ce secteur là donc
automatiquement les personnes qui vont
les usagers vont augmenter
donc le choix de la région c'est il faut
qu'il soit plutôt de se dire il faut que
j'améliore mes mes transports parce que
je demande
parce que le dans le cadre de du striff
il est demandé notamment à l'Essonne
d'augmenter en fait la capacité de de
logement donc si on augmente la capacité
de logement il va falloir aussi que les
transports suivent
je demande dans le cadre de ce collectif
Stop galère vous réclamez également le
retour immédiat donc de l'offre 100% des
transports les conditions de travail
n'étant plus attractives le secteur des
difficultés à recruter des chauffeurs
obligeant donc à réduire le nombre de
trains ou de bus en circulation et en
dégradant donc cette qualité de service
public comment est-ce qu'on peut y
remédier
au statut de fonctionnaire avant c'était
fonctionnaire et ça se passait plutôt
bien aujourd'hui on voit bien que ils
ont fait le choix de privatiser et de de
casser le statut et quand ce n'est plus
attractif ça ne fonctionne pas c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui ils sont en train
de former des jeunes peut-être que ces
jeunes là ne resteront même pas sur sur
leur carrière donc il faut donner des
perspectives en disant voilà vous avez
la possibilité d'évoluer d'une évolution
de carrière c'est important aussi et
surtout de travailler dans de bonnes
conditions et on revient toujours vous
avez vu toujours aux conditions de
travail
et ça c'est ça qui fait qui que le
gouvernement n'a pas compris tant que
les conditions de travail ne sont pas
améliorés et ne sont pas très bonnes les
gens ne veulent plus travailler comme ça
depuis le covid on l'a vu le changement
de de travail à en fait depuis la covid
ça a changé depuis la covid les gens
veulent donner du sens à leur travail
ils veulent mieux travailler le
changement de mentalité complètement
pour vous la privatisation des
transports en commun n'est pas une
solution si le service public n'arrive
pas à mettre en œuvre justement des
conditions de travail attractives et
bonne pourquoi ne pas laisser sa chance
justement
le sas public il est pas but lucratif
par comme comme le privé le privé il est
il doit faire il doit dégager du
bénéfice et des marges sur quoi votre
avis va le faire pas sur les trains pas
sur pas sur les rails mais sur quoi donc
soit sur la qualité de transport sur le
personnel et sur le nombre de trains de
passage de train
donc si on diminue le nombre de passages
si on diminue personnels on fait on fait
des économies donc ça sera moins
efficace de toute façon
on l'a bien vu avec tout ce qui a été
privatisé ne fonctionne pas ou
fonctionne très mal et donc du coup on
fait marche arrière à chaque fois on l'a
vu avec EDF dans le même temps donc la
majorité poursuit sa politique des zones
à faibles émission en Île-de-France les
voitures critères 4 et 5 ne peuvent déjà
plus circuler en semaine dans Paris et
ses alentours et en juillet ce sera
autour normalement des critères 3
Valérie Pécresse demande donc le report
de 18 mois de cette mesure est-ce qu'en
l'état actuel du service des transports
dont on vient de parler régional les
ADFE sont-elles adaptées
une voiture électrique
et avec les problématiques qu'on a connu
cet hiver
d'approvisionnement électrique qui est
vu le montant et ceux qui travaillent en
banlieue c'est qui habite en banlieue
c'est pas les plus riches donc ils ont
pas forcément les moyens et même si il
le voulait
et même si vous voulez changer de
voiture
vu que il y a d'autres d'autres postes
de charges qui ont augmenté avec la
place donc etc ils ne peuvent pas on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui déjà ils font
ils sont obligés de choisir soit se
nourrir soit
de payer leur loyer ou leur charge donc
on voit bien que ça peut pas tenir en
fait et on peut pas dire aux gens vous
avez acheté une voiture vous avez galéré
vous avez pris à crédit sur 10 ans et
maintenant elle est déjà plus valable
donc il va falloir reprendre un crédit
plus cher avec un véhicule qui coûte
deux fois ou trois fois plus cher pour
justement aller travailler c'est pas
possible donc vous êtes pour le report
de cette et surtout je suis pour que
pour l'écologie c'est plutôt bien sauf
qu'il faut se donner les moyens c'est
soit les transports on les adapte les
transports de façon correcte et c'est à
dire on se dit bah voilà on se donne les
moyens et on met tout sur les transports
on mise tout on mise de l'argent on a
fait voter dans le cadre du budget 3
milliards d'euros pour les transports
balayer d'un coup de 49-3 donc si on met
pas les moyens financiers pour améliorer
les conditions de transport des
transports publics on ne pourra pas
mettre en place cette
leur système c'est pas possible que
pensez-vous aussi de la proposition du
président du conseil départemental de
l'Essonne qui souhaite donc pousser à la
création de voix de bus express pour
relier les villes de grande couronne à
au Grand Paris et aux futurs Paris
Express
déjà sur quel foncée veulent faire parce
que il faut quand même du foncier donc
je vois pas sur quel foncier sur
l'autoroute il y a des voix spécialisées
spécifiques dédiées
notamment sur la 6
lignes de bus donc qui notamment je
pense en Essonne sur line N20 ou sur
l'autoroute
puisqu'il y a même le 151 qui qui va
jusqu'à gare jusqu'à Porte d'Orléans en
tout cas beaucoup plus de
l'argent moi je veux bien au contraire
développer les lignes de bus c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt bien mais avec quel
argent dernier non dernière question
Farida Amrani sur la question de la
mobilité durable les Parisiens la mairie
de Paris donc va mettre fin aux
trottinette électrique la décision a été
actée par un référendum dans lequel donc
peu de Parisiens se sont déplacés en
7,45%. ont voté alors pourtant en grande
couronne ce mode de transport se déploie
de plus en plus dans les Yvelines et
dans l'Essonne dans votre
circonscription les villes comme Évry 6
mètres qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ce
mode de transport on a toujours un train
de retard vous savez on banlieue par
rapport à Paris toujours
donc la mère de Paris a décidé par
référendum mais en fait ça l'arrange
puisque elle aurait pu dire bon il y a
pas assez on peut ça c'est un arrange je
pense qu'elle avait besoin de de
rendre ce référendum en disant voilà moi
je consulte la population etc c'est son
choix
je pense que il faut il faut c'est c'est
un moyen de transport qui peut être
intéressant j'ai pas de souci là-dessus
mais
quand il pleut on le voit bien ça
fonctionne pas forcément il faut il faut
des voies spécifiques aux trottinette
sécurisé
et on peut on peut pas aller très loin
avec trottinette et on le voit bien
on a besoin d'aller loin et donc c'est
pas que les trottinettes qu'on va régler
le problème d'aller loin merci beaucoup
Merci à VOUS Farid d'avoir été avec nous
je rappelle donc que vous êtes la
première vous êtes la député LFI de la
première circonscription de l'Essonne
l'hebdo politique c'est terminé vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur notre chaîne YouTube radio
sensation et aussi sur TV 78 on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]